[Musique]
Madeleine et burgen est une sportive de
haut niveau étudiante en kinésiologie et
membre de l'équipe d'athlétisme de
l'Université de Windsor et l'Excel au
saut en hauteur
mais l'an dernier et la failli de voir
mettre un terme à sa carrière sportive
j'avais tout le temps froid je me
blessais constamment j'ai eu une
fracture de stress à mon fémur à force
de trop couvrir
ça a commencé à affecter mes globules
blancs mes reins et mon foie
Madeleine souffre d'anorexie mental non
seulement elle mangeait très peu mais
elle s'entraînait excessivement jusqu'à
4 heures par jour 7 jours sur 7 ça a
commencé quand j'avais 13 ans j'ai reçu
un diagnostic d'anorexie et de
dépression
et depuis ça a été difficile
ça a pris le contrôle d'une partie de ma
vie
la jeune femme de 21 ans a été
hospitalisée plusieurs fois depuis le
début de l'adolescence elle a suivi de
nombreux traitements des médicaments
pour réduire ses symptômes d'anxiété et
de dépression ainsi que de la
psychothérapie mais sans grand succès
c'est que les troubles alimentaires
comme l'anorexie sont très difficiles à
traiter même lorsque la patiente comme
Madeline veut s'en sortir
mes pensées mes émotions sont toujours
en conflit depuis quelques années je
veux aller mieux je veux être en santé
mais mon trouble alimentaire travaille
dans la direction opposée
c'est vraiment difficile
derrière les troubles alimentaires se
cachent des habitudes très tenaces
nous n'avons pas de médicaments qui
traite directement les symptômes des
troubles alimentaires comme c'est le cas
par exemple pour la dépression
l'anorexie à l'un des plus haut taux de
mortalité en santé mentale à côté des
troubles d'abus de substance
parmi ceux qui ne guérissent pas une
personne sur dix va en mourir
spécialisé en troubles alimentaires à
Toronto Madeleine et burgen et sa
patiente depuis deux ans
il y a une partie de notre cerveau qui a
une sorte d'autopilote et chez certains
l'autopilote peut rester bloquée alors
quand il tente de changer quelque chose
ils sont submergés par l'anxiété vous
pouvez avoir une discussion avec un
patient il peut comprendre pourquoi il a
besoin de reprendre du poids et de
manger il est très raisonnable mais deux
heures plus tard il peut être devant de
la nourriture et être envahi par
l'anxiété à l'idée de changer sa routine
cet AutoPilote dans le cerveau a suscité
l'intérêt du chercheur en neurosciences
Salah el mystikhaoui
il y a des points communs entre
l'addiction l'anorexie la boulimie et
les troubles compulsifs où il y a cette
dimension de fer et refaire une action
malgré les conséquences négatives alors
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
à l'Institut de glace le chercheur a
étudié la source de ce
compte dans le cerveau
de les étudiés depuis longtemps et on
s'est beaucoup de choses sur elle donc
elles sont normales dans un
environnement normal sera mais elles ont
un truc c'est elle manque de flexibilité
elles sont un peu psychorigides quand
elles apprennent à faire un truc elles
vont avoir du mal si on change de
consigne et moi elle va avoir du mal à
faire autre chose il a voulu comprendre
ce qui favorise ce type de justement
dans le cerveau dans l'espoir de pouvoir
le corriger il s'est intéressé au
striatum cette région du cerveau
comprend notamment le noyau à combats
qui fait partie du centre de la
récompense le noyau codé quant à lui
dirige nos comportements orientés vers
un but et le putamen est responsable de
la création d'habitude
le noyau à combatse et le noyau codé
nous aide à apprendre de nouvelles
tâches par exemple conduire une voiture
puis le butamen prend le relais pour
transformer cette action en automatisme
alors il faut savoir que ce mode est un
mode qui nous rend très efficace un mode
super important et vous voyez que la
progression de tout ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un apprentissage
normal ces trois zones du cerveau
travaillent ensemble pour assurer notre
survie chaque sous-région a un frein un
accélérateur quelque chose qui va vous
dire ah il y a un billet de 100 dollars
on va le chercher ou si tu manges ça tu
vas mourir donc quelque chose qui va
vous faire faire l'action ou faire vous
bloquer l'action c'est la dopamine qui
compte la dopamine quand elle arrive
dans ces structures elle va appuyer sur
l'accélérateur et elle va bloquer le
frein le frein marche plus
la mine dans le par rapport aux deux
autres sous régions on appuie sur
l'accélérateur des comportements
automatiques c'est là que se manifeste
des troubles comme l'anorexie qui
deviennent difficiles à contrôler
cela elle m'estitaoui a donc identifié
un eurotransmetteur l'acide colline qui
augmente la dopamine dans le noyau à
condense et dans le noyau codé mais sans
toucher au butamen
en rétablissant l'équilibre en dopamine
entre ces trois zones on vient réduire
l'influence des comportements
automatiques ça va permettre une reprise
de contrôle puisque les deux autres
régions vont redevenir plus puissantes
qu'elles ne l'était précédemment mais
comment augmenter l'acidecholine dans le
cerveau la réponse n'était pas évidente
le chercheur l'a trouvé dans un
médicament utilisé pour traiter certains
problèmes cognitifs dans la maladie
d'Alzheimer il s'agit du denipisile la
cycline à neurotransmetteur très
particulier en fait ce qu'elle a une
enzyme comme un Pacman qui découpe la
silicone en deux morceaux et qu'il a
l'active en faisant ça ce que fait le
dernier pacil c'est que il vient se
loger dans le site actif de cet enzyme
il va la bloquer d'accord donc en
faisant ça qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il
va empêcher la dégradation de la saisie
de colline et donc il va prolonger
l'action il va augmenter les taux
d'acétroline à l'extérieur des neurones
pour tester son hypothèse il a donné ce
médicament à des sourires rendus
anorexiques en laboratoire
en les privant graduellement de
nourriture durant la journée on peut
amener des souris à préférer courir
plutôt que de manger
certaines se mettent alors à courir
presque sans arrêt même lorsque la
nourriture le rite verte de nouveau on
utilise un critère chez la souris à quel
moment j'ai perdu plus que 25% de mon
poids de base et quand on est en dessous
de cette zone on rentre dans une zone de
grande danger pour la santé etc et on
enclenche un processus qui est
l'anorexie en fait et quand on donne à
ce groupe là le dernier paisible hop la
cour remonte au même niveau que les
souris contrôles les souris anorexiques
traités aux données paisibles recommence
donc à s'alimenter normalement mais pour
vérifier si cela fonctionne aussi chez
l'humain le chercheur s'est adressé à la
docteur Léo rapinas la psychiatre l'a
essayé avec certains de ses patients à
des doses beaucoup plus faibles que ce
qui est habituellement prescrit dans le
traitement de l'Alzheimer j'avais dit
allez aura que je pensais que le donner
paisible allait relativement rapidement
agir sur le la composante flexibilité et
compulsivité et c'est exactement ce
qu'elle m'a décrit et c'est incroyable
parce que justement même avec des doses
extrêmement faibles du médicament les
effets anticompulsifs ils sont c'est
super rapide
je crois que j'ai remarqué la différence
en un mois parfois moins c'est
remarquable Madeleine et burgen a vu des
résultats impressionnants
à reprendre le contrôle de ce que je
veux faire
avant j'avais l'objectif de prendre soin
de ma santé mais je ne me sentais pas
capable d'effectuer ces changements
avec le médicament ça m'aide à surmonter
l'anxiété que je ressentais quand je
tentais de faire ces changements
c'était une patiente qui avait tout
essayé et qui était vraiment coincé dans
un état qui affectait sa vie
durant deux ans nous tentions de
l'amener à réduire son temps
d'entraînement de 5 ou 10 minutes par
jour et nous n'y arrivions pas
[Musique]
quelques semaines après avoir commencé
le médicament elle a réussi à augmenter
la variété de ce qu'elle mangeait et
elle a pu réduire son temps
d'entraînement de moitié
doublé la taille de ces portions
alimentaires et à la maintenant un point
santé la psychiatre a vu des résultats
similaires chez une demi-douzaine de ses
patients jusqu'à maintenant mais le
dernier épisode a des risques il
augmente la pression artérielle de façon
importante et il peut donc être
dangereux pour des patients dont la
santé physique est déjà fragile c'est
pourquoi cela elle m'estikawi travaille
sur une nouvelle molécule qui aura la
même action sur le cerveau mais sans les
effets secondaires on travaille des
chimistes on a modifié la molécule elle
ne sera plus active dans le corps mais
elle passera dans le cerveau elle
deviendra active elle marche très bien
chez souris voilà donc ça c'est c'est
vraiment une très très bonne nouvelle
en attendant que cette nouvelle molécule
soit prête le denipisile reste une
solution temporaire mais qui peut
changer des vies
j'ai pu guérir des blessures que j'avais
l'an dernier
je n'ai plus de douleur partout
j'ai plus d'énergie et je n'ai plus tout
le temps froid
je vais beaucoup mieux je cours plus
rapidement je suis beaucoup plus forte
et j'espère que je pourrais
compétitionner cette année
les jeunes gens avec qui je travaille
sont extraordinaires ils sont
intelligents travaillant attentionnés de
pouvoir les aider à reprendre le cours
de leur vie au lieu de gaspiller des
décennies en temps et en ressources
c'est pour ça que je suis allé en
médecine
d'avoir un enfant anorexique
c'est moi c'est quelque chose qui me
bouleverse j'ai connu de près un cas
proche d'une jeune fille extrêmement
brillante qui a mis fin à ses jours
c'est je pense c'est une des choses qui
m'a motivé pour pour faire de la
recherche sur l'anorexie et là on en est
vraiment au tout début mais c'est le
début d'une révolution début d'un grand
changement dans ce domaine c'est un
signal d'espoir quand même pour les
familles et pour les patients
[Musique]